this was taken seconds before a
Ukrainian passenger jet crashed near
Tehran security cameras captured the
dramatic moment of impact on the ground
176 people died including 63 Canadians
that country's Prime Minister says it
was downed by an Iranian missile we have
intelligence from multiple sources
including our allies and our own
intelligence the evidence indicates that
the plane was shot down by an Iranian
surface-to-air missile the plane came
down just four hours after Iran had
fired a volley of missiles towards the
US bases in Iraq the country wasn't high
alert for possible us retaliation asked
if he blamed America for escalating
tensions in the area Prime Minister
Trudeau said a full investigation was
needed before fingers were pointed I
think it is too soon to be drawing
conclusions or assigning blame or
responsibility and whatever proportions
Iranian officials insist the aircraft
are Ukrainian international boeing
737-800 had a problem and was headed
back to the airport they say there were
other planes in the area debris from the
plane was scattered over a wide area
the so-called black box is a cockpit
voice recorder and a flight data
recorder have been recovered the Iranian
say they won't be handing them over to
Boeing but will conduct an investigation
and keep Ukraine informed it's been
reported that debris has been build
those into a pile at the scene making a
forensic analysis almost impossible but
one expert told us the Dead might be the
best witnesses there could be evidence
with literally within the bodies of the
victims that could point to whether or
not for example the explosion took place
inside or outside of the aircraft
earlier in the day US President Donald
Trump said he feared the worst it was
flying in a pretty rough neighborhood
and somebody could have made a mistake
some people say it was mechanical I
personally don't think that's even a
question the Ukrainian president laid
flowers at a makeshift memorial at the
airport where the plane was due to land
he called for Canadian experts to join
the investigation it's understood many
of the victims have dual nationalities
families are now painfully waiting to
find out when the bodies will be
returned
and they can see their final goodbyes
and more with Alan now in Washington now
let's talk about this new video first of
all because you know when we saw the
initial pictures yesterday there's some
thought oh it looks like it's on fire as
it goes down but now we're seeing it
tried to turn around it was a small
explosion it's quite something to watch
the Iranians and says the the the plane
had a problem that's why it was turning
around heading back towards the airport
and they insist that given that it came
down on its belly that shows that it
wasn't blowing out of the sky that there
wasn't a catastrophic impact with a
missile
well the Canadians want to be able to
investigate they say they've got to have
a full comprehensive and transparent
investigation that is why a number of
their inspectors have already traveled
to Turkey they're waiting for approval
from the Iranians to go into the country
they have no diplomatic relations with
Tehran so this is all being done through
the Italians but they hope to get people
on the ground sooner rather than later
particularly as I said in the report
we're hearing that at the site some of
the wreckage has been bulldozed together
which would make it difficult to carry
out an investigation not impossible but
very difficult and as early expert said
there is a real possibility that the
silent witnesses might be able to talk
here the victims that have been lying on
the ground that boarded that plane
thinking they were going back to Ukraine
they might be able to give the
inspectors some sort of indication
exactly what happened inspectors so
Iranian territory Ukrainian plane
lots of Canadians on board and the
Canadians say they want to be involved a
lot I mean who leads theirs how does it
all sort of come together well normally
when there is a plane crash it is the
country where the accident happened so
it would be Iran and they have primacy
in this issue and normally they would
invite people from the manufacturers
which in this case would be boring the
difficulty of course is Boeing is an
American company and the enmity between
Iran and the United States particularly
at the moment no we are told that some
Boeing inspectors will
be given access to the site but when it
comes to analyzing the two recorders on
board the Iranians are suggesting there
may be some problem with that that there
may be some damage to that and also that
they will not be handing those boxes
over to Boeing the Ukrainians obviously
want to be kept fully informed they have
asked for the Canadians to help form
part of an international investigation
they believe that their expertise would
be very beneficial this will play out
over the next few days that's normal
after a crash like this but what is
clear is that Canada is on standby to
take action Justin Trudeau was asked
look if it is proven that this was a
missile what action will you take he
repeatedly said we have to carry out a
full investigation before we start even
talking about responses and what he made
clear is this might have been a mistake
there is the possibility according to
one person I spoke to earlier that if
this was the Russian missile system that
they say it was then it may have been
left on remember the timing of this it
was just four hours after the Iranians
fired a volley of missiles towards US
bases in Iraq they were concerned about
u.s. retaliation the missile defense
systems were switched on it's possible
they were still an automatic and that
this plane came within the area of that
missile defense system and was short out
of the sky but at the moment that
remains speculation the Canadians and
others want answers and they say the
best way to do that is to make this
investigation international full
comprehensive and transparent lots more
to come on this one then Alan Fisher in
Washington thank you